oh
[Music]
back
1 2 three hi everyone happy to see you
here thank for joining and welcome to
user experience
Workshop um but before we start raise
your hand if you a product visual or you
a
designer no okay okay
sorry right the hand if you're marketer
product manager or founder
this one thanks and raise your hand if
you are Developer engineer of
QA oh my happy to see here also uh
thanks so much nice to meet you um I'm
happy that you interested in this topic
this Workshop will be relevant for
everyone uh because regardless who you
are we are users of the applications on
different
devices um some of them are better than
others why do you think why ux
M 100 points uh if you if you compare uh
the applications with similar
functionality a better application will
have an excellent user
experience and today we will learn about
user experience research in product
development the types of research best
practices and common
mistakes um please raise hand who is
familiar with user research tools
can you name some of
them yes cool yeah and there are lot of
them uh you always know know
and we will learn also about custom in a
map and how to visualize user paino
motivations and potential improvements
and the question is who had the
experience with working working with
customer Journey
map wow okay cool and we'll practice
Techni interviews in groups and analyze
the results creating customer Jour
map and at the end you'll know what US
research is how to conduct user
interview creating a customer journ map
and build the best experience for your
users hi my name is Andre B I'm product
designer at matter lab the creators of
ZK sync before the blockchain
I've been in product design and user
experience for over 10 years always with
a focus on the end
users for example I created the personal
medical assistant for clients uh of
public hospitals and AI assistant for
lawyers long before the AI
hype and for me user Centric design is
essential I believe in good design
principle inspired by J lams the famous
industrial designer who know who know
fim influential work at Brown and the
functionalist School of industrial
design good design means creating
solution that are Innovative useful
aesthetically clear honest long lasting
and as minimal as
possible and in 2017 I entered the
blockchain space to improve the user and
budging starting with working with
centralized crypto exchanges and then in
2022 I joined maaps where I focus on
helping developer deliver a simless
blockchain experience using C Ed
Technologies and user Centric
design and to bring this Vision we began
to implement native account obstruction
in short it's a different type of
account powered by custom code and can
be secured by different thing other than
a SE phrase this custom code allows you
to have a lot of functions like
increasing security recovering options
and paying gas for someone
else this is why you can have a lot of
options to unboard your users and you
might think okay just to use the best
possible stack ever and everything
should work perfectly right um and this
is partially true been but knowing your
stack is the one part of the solution
without understanding your users even
the best tools will not work for
them the question for you who often ERS
something from different online
stores uh for example uh
okay let's can uh you have uh the
purchase something in new online store
if you compare it with the previous
store you used before what this new
online store should do to make your
experience smooth and simplest as
possible
H
yeah another
yes MH
yeah let me check it on this
example yeah the similarity Amazon chard
for example uh has multiple steps but
user find it intuitive because it's
familiar a small store might offer a
simple wi page check out which can cause
friction because it's too far from user
expectation make things familiar to your
users and they will love your product so
how how we can make
it we have learned them this is why user
experience can help
us and but what is user experience
according to nilson Norman group user
experience includes all the aspects of
the interaction between the end user the
company its services and its
products uh you can visit this company
website uh uh because they have nice
articles on ux which you can read to
learn
more to know more about this interaction
we have to provide user research this
help up deeply understand our users what
they need what they value their
abilities and their
limitations why do we need user research
it provides direct insight into what
user needs the pain points and how they
behave and it guides our decision making
product development more focused and
effective and ultimately it reduces risk
and leads the higher user
satisfaction what are the ways to
research users what we can do to learn
them
yes what else what we can do now why we
can find
them
yeah so can ask microphone because
everyone will here hello um we can study
or reverse engineer even applications or
web pages that have considered a good
user experience so we can learn what
makes them actually good products yes
and what else we can do to learn our
users how you learn
them
yeah yeah the lot of things we can find
them on the street we can find them
whatever you want it's not a problem uh
the but in
general uh user research comes into two
main forms uh qual qualitative and
quantitative uh qualitative research
dives into why behind behind user
actions uh when quantitative resource
focuses on measurable patterns and data
together they G give us both deep and
scale and understanding our
users
um what do we think is the quantitative
or qualitative research we should use
first
why any igas also
yeah yeah in general everyone will be
correct everything will be correct
because quantitative methods I usually
use it first because you can capture
more data that you can use to create in
depth interview
questions also I like to use surveys a
quantitative method uh to find user we
can invite for in-depth interview
optionally asking them to leave their
contacts but sometimes uh you can start
with qualitative method uh if you have
just a few potential users it can be
possible in healthcare when uh you have
a few users with specific needs
and wine
product before we dive into qualitative
research and practice it uh let's
briefly cover quantitative method
quantitative research gather numbers
that can be analyzed
statistically even it's essential for
making data driven decision optimizing
designs and identifying patterns in user
Behavior at
scale why do we need it quantitative
research is essential when when we need
a measurable data driven insight to
guide our design decisions it help us to
collect numerical data that can be
analyzed to reveal pattern Trends and
relationships uh when we do when do we
need quantitative research it's
essential for measuring user Behavior at
scale for example it's useful for
tracking metrics like conversion rate
and drop off points
to validate hypothesis and confirm the
impact of design
changes to make datadriven design
decision based on real user
interaction for identifying patterns or
Trends in the user Behavior over
time to evaluate future performance
through measurable
metcs to Benchmark and track progress
against qpi and competitors
to prioritize design Improvement by
identifying issues that affect to most
users support business objectiv by
linking y Improvement to revenue and
user
engagement and when statistical
confidence is required for high impact
decision and when inside from a large
representative database I
needed the Practical tips you can use in
quantitative methods
surveys creating them keep question
clear precise and unbiased when use uh
use a mix of closed questions like
multiple choice and open question to
gather both structured and detail
Insight you can use for this Google
forms type form and serve
monkey another tool is
Abit this lets you measure uh measure
the impact of Chang it by tting one
variable at the time like pattern color
or col to action
text and also you can track key
performance indicator that aligns you uh
with your goals such as page view time
on page bounce rate
Etc and heat map heat Maps shows which
areas of your website user engage with
most and which are
ignored and three testing this testing
help validate your site information AR
architecture by asking user to find
specific content and tracking their
success but what about qualitative usern
research qualitative user research
focuses on understanding why and
how behind user behaviors motivations
and
emotions qualitative research user uh
user interviews usability texting and
field studies uh to gather in depth
insights the focus is on understanding
the needs pain points and experiences
giving us valuable context for user
Centric
design in which case we need qualitative
research for example understanding user
needs and motivations allow us to deeply
explore why user behave a certain way
and uncover the pain
points also exploring new idea or
concepts when generating or testing
early stage ideas or
design explaining and anomalias in
quantitative data to understand the
reasons behind unexpected patterns of
behaviors and open Real World context to
study how user interact with product in
their natural
environment and improving usability to
identify where user encounter friction
or
confusion to capture how user feel about
the product and their overall
experience and designing for news
special User Group when working with
specific user types you have unique
needs or
workflows and check the design progress
to GA feedback on prototypes on new
designs for
improvements and understanding long-term
user
behaviors and addressing culture and
social factors when designing for Global
or diverse User
Group practical tips what we can use in
this
research Define clear objectives always
being with clear research goals know
exactly which user behaviors needs or
emotions you want to
investigate choose right participants
select participant who reflect your
target audience or user persons a small
careful choosing group 5 10 people is
more than enough for having valuable
insights use open question
ask question they from theils response
like why do why do you prefer this
future or how does this process make you
feel for example instead of do you like
this future you can ask what do you like
or dis like about this
feature and create comfortable
environment to make user feel relaxed
the more comfortable they are the more
honest and detailed the feedback will be
for example let and know that they're
not right or wrong answers you are
simply interested interested in their
personal
experience observe natural interaction
during interview or usability testing
let user interact with a product freely
without
guidance and please always record
session with permission of course and
take detailed note to capture nonverbal
cues tone and behaviors that act
insights
and always when user share interesting
feedback uh ask followup questions to
explore further use phrases like can you
explain more why did you feel like that
to deeper insights for example if user
dislike a feature ask um what they would
change to improve
it analyze your data for repeated topics
behaviors or pain points across user to
enover Common Trends and key
insights and use nonverbal cues like
body language facial expression and tone
as they can reveal emotion or discomfort
beyond
words and Inter inter Bas based on the
feedback inside from qualitative
research will help you to refine design
and test them to overcome identify
issues so finally before start
tell objective as to participant
background consider participant
background expertise product familiarity
and demographics when preparing
objectives or
questions please prepare semi structed
guide with cor question to keep the
interview natural yet focused this
prevents long poses when helps you
smoothly transition to new topics after
deep
discussion build connection
at inside the town create relaxed
nonjudgment atmosphere to help
participant feel comfortable I start
with casual questions and remember to
thank them for joining at the
beginning timing if you have multiple
interview schedle break between them use
this time to rest take notes prepare for
the next session or ask additional
prayer interview
questions and stay flexible and open
your guide guide is important but adjust
as the conversation flows if participant
share something unexpected and
insightful uh explore it even if it
wasn't in your initial
plan so let's
practice and our first task is in inep
interview our topic personal journey in
the blockchain
world um this is an excellent topic for
today because everyone joined the
blockchain industry in their own way
whether you're a beginner or have some
experience just being here today shows
us you you have taken steps to learn
about this space uh by the way some of
the most valuable Insite come from the
people who are still exploring if they
can reveal unique challenge about
blockchain divide into pair of
two one person will conduct the
interview for the first 5 minutes
another person will conduct uh the
interview for other five minutes
interviewer please ask question listen
and clarify if necessary respondent
please respond the
questions um please don't avoid
participation if you don't have if you
don't want to participate as interview
or respondant you can get another role
as Observer Observer following the
interview you can help take notes for
the
answer open this document you this is
editable document includes the template
you can use and add your
answers each person must use one
template you can also see uh the example
of the questions I will show you right
now uh I divided the question example
you can use into different stages the
first stage is early experience and
obstacles can you describe your first
experience with a blockchain product for
example W setup purchasing crypto using
DBS um what challenges did you face when
you first tried using blockchain tools
for example complexity lack of guidance
security
concern and other St uh stages like
early experience and
obstacles learning process current
engagement
feedbacks and closing inside all the
questions you can see on that
document so let's start interview divide
in the group of two persons uh one is
asking first five minute uh second uh
person is asking second next five
minutes and please feel the response if
you don't want to use a website or or
you don't have a laptop you can use the
papers here or here and uh take the
answers so please divide on group of two
persons
if you're able it's better to use laptop
and you can text any answers on the
laptop yeah yeah
if you have any additional question
please uh come to me I I'll will help
you you can just ask your friend just
about uh General blockchain experience
and you can use the question I prepared
in the document
hello I just have questions
okay understood yeah
uh here you can call uh please attention
please attention there are a lot of
templates uh please scroll down and
choose your specific template so you can
scroll down and see more and more
templates uh you can use one template
one template is the person who is asking
the question so just enter the respon
you will
receive so we just use one of yeah there
a lot of yeah there are a lot of
template please scroll down and choose
empty template for your personal
you need this one show no not
now e
mhm
yeah
e
e for
if you don't want what by the way if you
don't want what if you don't know what
to do on the link you can scroll down uh
and see other templates you can use any
of them
what the light
hello hello please change your Ro
now second person is asking the
question
e e
spe
e for
[Music]
St
e e
spe
5 minutes
left
e e
fr
e
e for
if you have question please raise your
hand and I will
come e
okay guys let's stop our uh practice
this and attention please we have to
continue I love how you are working but
we have to continue to capture more
information about that
um so okay let's stop our interview now
we have many many insights what we can
do with
them sorting and classification of
insights organize the collected insight
into categories of topics there many
there there may be familiar similar PS
needs or behavior
patterns uh
for example categorize your pain points
um like technical issues lack of
knowledge interface complexity security
fears Etc so you can you have your
answers you can just categorize them
make groups and to to to figure out what
main main groups you have from that
answers please group your
answers if you have any question please
raise your hand
you can use the same document or paper
if you use before and on the same
document on the right side you can see
groups you can use that or just use
papers
yes a lot of papers are nearby the door
so you can you can go and have papers on
the door near by the
water e
here
your
okay guys uh what so now we have some
groups we have a lot of answers we C
categorize them in few groups
and what we what we can do next um in
general it's very nice to use effort
impact matx you can use the same
document as you can see on the right
side this Matrix um please add uh let's
have prioritization session determine
which insights and problems are the most
critical to solve uh to do this you can
use the Matrix of priorities according
to such criterias like importance of the
problem to user and potential product
impact to the business you can use the
same document or on paper whatever you
want and please uh do that next five
minutes if you have any question let
your
hand let's focus a little bit more what
it is uh if we have the problem we can
solve and this will impact a lot for the
business we have we have to have it uh
it cost a lot but we have a lot of
things uh business will be happy on that
it will be on the right uh top Top PA if
we have some problems which uh we can do
quickly like fix something change the
text change the button it will be uh and
it will have a lot of impact to the
business it will be on the left top
part if we have something that is very
very hard to solve and very very low
impact it will have it's like feel in
job it's left down downside but if we
have low impact and high effort it will
be than like
St so if you have something you can fix
it cost a lot
um and no impact to the business this is
than tasks
let's cover the groups you can use the
groups you have groups name after
categorizing and use this group names to
add to this document you can see this on
the document I showed you
here on the template if you have
additional question please raise your
hand
e
for e
show
e
e e
okay what next um in general we done
amazing job analyzing all interviews
help help identify key points and find
issues across different groups
so attention attention attention please
thanks so
much uh what next uh sometimes you can
figure out that you can create the
personas uh seever because you can you
can have several main personas like uh
that Persona should reflect user needs
uh with their needs problems and
motivation for example like this oh
sorry oh my God for example like this
you can have some blockchain newb and
good experien at blockchain users and
this it can be different
personas what next we can the last topic
we have covered today is customer
Journey map why it's important because
this is visual representation of steps
and experiences that a customer goes
through when interacting with the
product services or
brand it's like step by step from first
seeing the product to finishing main
flow and it helped to understand the
user experience from their perspective
identifying pain
points um emotion and reaction during
their
interaction and the goal is to improve
the user experience by pinpointing area
where the process can be optimized or
where user encounter friction
so this is the example you can you
someone can see that in uh the documents
I show before this is the example of
customer Journey map on the left column
you see all the user steps of
interaction with a product customer
Journey map uh lets you explain the
steps in details and check the users's
reaction key component of customer
Journey map Persona this is usually
based on user research or represents
specific type of customer
with their different needs behaviors and
goals for example new blockchain user or
developer integrating the blockchain
like this uh stages represent different
steps uh of customer goes through during
the journey this identifying stages uh
the stage helped us identify and break
down the overall experience and
highlight where we should make
improvements touch points um when
customer interacting with elements in
the environment and the interface device
whatever they have different touch
points like app store or wallet
application customer action here um
customer action mean what users do at
each stage like downloading application
or set uping the wallet customer
thoughts uh reveal what user thinks at
each point of the journey
and my favorite emotions emotions show
how us are feeling during the journey
mapping this emotion help identify area
that need
improvements to create the more positive
experience pain points are the obstacle
or challenges customers
face and opportunities here are are the
moments where you can enhance the
customer
experience why customer Jour map is
essential because a transform insights
you have today from our interview to
actionable strategies revealing pain
points and opportunities to
improve please uh let's create customer
Jour map you can use the product you are
working on right now or Insight you have
from the interview you conducted
today open the document uh on the link
you have uh you already have on the
right side of the template you have the
customer Journey template and please add
the when you are interacting and asking
the question you know uh the answers
like this person what this person did
first what next Donal application Don
wet Etc you can add all the stages onto
the customer Journey map so let's start
if you have any question raise your
hand
e
e e
hello guys uh please attention we have
to continue and we don't have a lot of
time so um let's um attention please
let's imagine you finish this it's very
cool to have uh because
it's very cool thing to discuss with
your team because um if you if your team
team members or product said okay we
have user that doing 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 you
always know some most important thing
but step three or four can be not
discuss it a lot and this table is super
cool for discussing with the team
members in
general but we did it what next BR stone
with the
team uh identify key problem s on the
customer J map and invite team members
who are related to a product to come
with a possible solution or option to
improve you can present your interview
result uh with customer gen map to the
stakeholders or
managers you can Bas on the DAT data you
collected develop a road map that
describe the steps to implement changes
and Improvement to the product determine
which is should be solved first using
that matics and who is responsible for
them be sure doc commend all insight and
conclusions from the interviews so they
will be available for future analysis
this can be done by uh using Google doc
or notion so all the team members uh can
share their ideas and
proposals let's build the product us a
love thank you
[Applause]
any
question I hope I answer on the question
by I was not by you yeah
please um what is the process at
metalabs to actually find people to
interview are those like random people
you've never met are they somehow
familiar with the projects you building
can you repeat please I didn't hear um
at metalabs what's the process of
actually finding people to do the
interviews with yeah finding people to
do interview okay um there are lot of
things we have nice Community uh a lot
of them are ready to discuss to share
the knowledge one of the things for
example I can share the Google form or
type form to Discord and ask them oh you
can find I have a
simple questions you can answer them for
example what the tool you are using how
your experience was what your the most
favorite this is something we can have
to control uh the general ux Impressions
and optionally I can leave the questions
you please leave your mail I can connect
with you if your experience is very
important and we can discuss more deeply
so this is one of the simplest way have
a lot of things but this is what I love
to do because our team members are um
community members are very
active this is it okay thanks so much
have a nice day
[Applause]
[Music]
he
back back
[Music]
back
back back back
[Music]
w
back
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
good
back
[Music]
back back
back back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
yeah you
[Music]
oh
o
[Music]
o oh
you
[Music]
n
ble B
[Music]
o
oh
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
e
back
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
he
back
[Music]
back back
back back back
see
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
hello everyone
hi thanks everyone for coming I'm uh
really excited that we've got a sizable
crew even though this classroom is
pretty much impossible to find I don't
know whether anyone else struggled to
find it yeah so congratulations you
passed the first test you can find uh a
classroom in the middle of nowhere um so
as you can see this will be all about
doing user research or ux research in
web 3 we're kind of going to use those
terms
interchangeably and uh I'm not doing
this myself there's another person you
wouldn't know because she's hiding right
behind me
uh and we're GNA walk you through this
beautiful journey of doing user
research Q
QR there's a Code yes so um because it's
a workshop you you don't have to only
ask your questions um using the the
mircat app but feel free to to do that
like we are going to check the app and
um at the end when we're doing Q&A if
there are any questions that there we
will answer
them um yeah so let's get
started nope yes these are our names
hello um just to give you an idea of
what this is going to all entail we're
going to start with intro and it's
already happening so look at us doing
great the first kind of half of this
Workshop is going to be a rash course in
ux research so what it is how to do it
what tools to use what not to do that's
also an important part of it and then
the second half will be an exercise when
you can apply all these um facts that
that you learned today and then we'll
have some time for
Q&A all right so um let us tell you a
little bit about ourselves uh Mindy
please emerge from your cave and tell us
a little bit about yourself
hi I'm also here my name is Mindy um
I've been working in uex since uh 2017
working in web 3 for about three years
now uh I am the senior ux contributor at
cow Dow we are uh building several
products including cow swap which you
may have heard of um didn't get any any
Applause that's sad
um thank
[Music]
you Cal team are you asleep what's going
on uh yeah and then my um my lovely um
assistant here not assistant wow
co-host yeah so my name is Christina my
pronouns are they them and I've been
working in crypto since uh 2018 most of
the time has been osis and then safe
this is where we hear thunderous
Applause for those
companies um mostly as a as a ux
researcher and uh I'm based in Berlin as
you can tell from how I
look all right so now you know a little
bit about us but we want to know about
you so yeah uh raise your hand if uh you
feel like you are a complete beginner in
terms of understanding ux user
experience on show put your hand
down okay very few people okay that's
really nice raise your hand if you feel
like you have like a pretty good
understanding of user experience user
research
what was it can we go back to question
one if you're a
beginner oh okay okay back to question
one raise your hand if you feel like
you're a beginner in
ux okay a few more people have decided
they feel like beginners raise your hand
if you feel like you you understand ux
pretty
well okay all right pretty good raise
your hand if you uh have already done
user research on a web 3
product Oh okay nice yes cow guys come
on
on okay good so yeah so the one's
already doing research great it's good
to see you here as well um this uh talk
is going to mostly be um sort of basic
um logistical information how to get
started doing user research but I think
there will be useful tips for people who
are at any level um of doing user
research or learning about user
research all right so um let's get down
to business what is ux research how does
one do it all that good
stuff so ux research is all about
understanding your users or your
potential users in order to make better
product decisions that's that's the
purpose of ux
research there are many many ways you
can do it and there are kind of two main
types there's quantitative and there's
qualitative for quantitative you usually
need more users for it to be
statistically significant 40 is about
how many you need for example for a
survey to be valid and this can tell you
how many people are having a certain
problem how much of a problem it is so
if you want to quantify certain facts
that you already know a little bit about
that's that's a good a good type of
method to choose there are many ways you
can do quantitative research there are
surveys card sorting tree testing
benchmarking if you have no idea what
these words mean don't worry
um we're not going to talk about those
today spoiler alord then there's the
qualitative side so there you can get
lots of information from just talking to
a few users so five people already
provide lots and lots of useful
information for you and the kind of
questions you might get answers for in
terms of qualitative research is why is
this happening why are you are users
behaving a certain way how do we fix
that is this solution suitable how do
people feel about it and common methods
for qualitative research include user
interviews usability testing diary
studies field studies again this is not
an exhaustive list at all uh people have
been really creative in terms of coming
up with different different ways to
conduct research so as you can see this
is an impressive list because we have
two hours we're going to do these two
this is what we're focusing on today and
the good news is these are quite easy to
learn and you can get a lot of value
from from doing this kind of research um
without spending too much time on
it so let's start with user interviews
what they are and how to do
those yes so uh user interviews I like
to summarize user interviews as um the
art of caring intensely for the space of
like 30 minutes to an hour uh about how
a total stranger thinks and feels so um
the way I will um kind of illustrate
this is you know how that that feeling
that you have when you're falling in
love with someone or you know you're
really infatuated someone and you just
met them and you just want to know
everything about them and you just like
they you just want to hear everything
that they what they that they think and
like every sentence out of their mouths
so interesting to you that's how you
need to feel about your user just for
the space of an hour afterwards you
don't have to care about them anymore
but for the space of that hour you have
to care so intensely about what they're
saying that's the mindset that you need
to be in in order to do user interview
effectively and um what I mean by that
uh is is that user interviews basically
are a way of uncovering your user's
needs um uncovering their pain points so
that you can optimize your product to
fit them so the goal is to learn as much
as possible about this person's thoughts
fears wishes needs habits um as related
to the area the topic of study uh so
that you can build a product that will
make their lives easier and make them
want to use it what do you need to do a
user interview uh is basically a list of
questions you need a participant
obviously um ideally this would be
somebody who is a user of your product
or somebody who is a potential user of
your product um and then you need a way
to take notes or to record the
conversation uh what can we learn from a
user interview specifically so from an
interview we'll learn what this person's
uh needs and wants are uh what's
important to them what people aren't
getting from existing Solutions uh that
are out there which could potentially be
advantages for you uh and then also how
people make decisions about which
products they use um and the trade-offs
associated with different using
different products in web
3 um now if you sit down to write a list
of interview questions uh for a user of
your product you might be tempted
immediately to ask things like will you
use this product uh do you like this
product isn't my idea really great um
and those are all terrible questions
don't ask them
ever um the goal is to get people to
open up and share anecdotes from their
lives this is not like um like a Q&A
interview um or you know like a I don't
know a survey this is really you want
them to be talking more than you're
talking um you need to get them engaged
in the conversation thinking deeply
about their answers and telling you oh
yeah and then there was this one time
where this happened and that's happened
that's when you get really interesting
moments from their lives where you're
like okay they actually really had a
problem here and I think maybe we can
solve this problem um so here are some
guidelines whoops here are some
guidelines um for writing these kinds of
questions uh the first one is to ask
specific questions general questions get
you general answers and you don't need
general answers uh when you're building
a product you might end up with
something like okay so I spoke to 10
users and they all told me that they use
exchanges a lot great how does that this
help me build my product uh compare that
to something more specific spefic like I
spoke to 10 people and eight of them
used an exchange in the last month to
swap meme coins okay that gives you more
information about what people are
actually doing and then ideally you get
the why about that as well and then
we're getting into the really
interesting specific data that can help
you uh Market your product or build your
product to to suit a particular audience
um you also want to ask open-ended
questions as much as possible not yes or
no questions at the end of your
interview you don't want a list of uh
check boxes yes no yes no uh again you
want those really detailed stories from
their lives um so you really want to ask
open-ended questions so then that the
participant can take that question and
and and start answering and then and
then snowball from there and take the
the topic to wherever they want to take
the topic to wherever is really
interesting for them or where they
really have a product to vent a project
a problem to vent about um another one
is don't ask leading questions um so
people will pick up if you have some bi
uh everybody has bias obviously we try
to keep that as low as possible uh when
we're doing research but if you ask bias
questions like um crypto is pretty
complicated huh then you already have
put that idea in their heads maybe they
weren't actually thinking that crypto
was that complicated um or maybe they
maybe they they they want to you know go
along with what you're saying they want
you to feel comfortable you know they
don't want to stand up against what
you're saying so they'll just go along
with that um so you instead want to ask
a very neutral question like you know
maybe how would you the complexity of
crypto and then see what they say about
that uh another is that you want to ask
about past experiences not future
predictions uh in Psychology we know
that people are pretty bad at predicting
their future Behavior Uh how many of you
have ever sworn that you were going to
start going to the gym regularly and
then not done
it
yeah
yeah okay everybody here goes to the gym
regularly another thing about user
interviews that sometimes people lie
yeah yeah as we see
here uh the point is that people are
really bad at predicting what they're
going to do in the future they might
have intentions to do something but it
doesn't mean they're going to do it and
they might do things that they had no
intention of doing um so it's always
better to ask uh about what people have
done in the past rather than asking them
to predict their own future which nobody
can really do um and then the last
guideline here is to always ask father
questions and this is where we really
get into that part of being in love with
the user because you know they say
something and we don't just say okay yep
that's all I needed thanks we continue
okay why did you do it that way oh my
gosh that's so interesting really would
you do it again the same way the next
time or or would you do something
differently if you could wave a magic
wand and like make it different you know
make something different about this
experience what would you how would you
do that can you imagine a better
experience can you imagine a worse
experience can you compare it with other
experiences if you had I any of these
these follow any follow-up questions
that comes to your mind is is useful and
it helps make that person feel like what
they're saying is important and it makes
them want to talk more uh and it gets
you really really uh indepth uh
qualitative data that you can then uh
use in in your product
building and uh
Christina smooth
transition um so that was user
interviews now I'm going to talk about
usability testing so there are some
similarities you are still talking to a
person but if you think about what you
just heard about user interviews you you
really really care deeply about this
person you want to know everything you
ask them all kinds of questions you're
really engaged you're really present
there usability testing is a slightly
different vibe so with theability
testing you're watching someone fail and
you just got to pretend like you don't
care at all you do care like let's let's
be clear in order to do good ux research
you need to have empathy you need to
really care about how people feel what
their struggles are that's all true but
on your face ain't nothing
happening so try to cultivate some kind
of inner
Serenity so suble someone stumbles and
you don't help them up the they ask for
directions and you don't provide any
it's kind of a struggle at first for
some of us but that's really how you get
the most valuable insights we'll get
into details about why in in a
moment but first let's talk about what
you need to do usability testing so
unlike user interviews that you can just
do you know sitting in a cafe with
someone for usability testing you need a
little bit more of a setup so you need
either a live product or a working
prototype and when I say working
prototype I don't mean it's you know
implemented in any way it can be just a
series of clickable screens in figma or
something like that that's totally fine
you also need a list of test scenarios
we'll get into that in a
moment again a participant it's kind of
sad to be just sitting on your own uh
trying to imagine things um side note AI
is not a participant you need a human
participant so um same as with the user
interviews it needs to be either someone
who's already your user or is similar
enough to someone who your user might be
and you need a way to take notes or
ideally record the screen as the
participant uses the product because
that's how you're going to really see
what they're doing see what they're
clicking on see their thought process
through the way that their cursor moves
that's all super super useful stuff you
don't want to miss it and that way you
kind of will be able to uncover those
problems with your design so that you
can improve them in terms of clarity and
flow and ease of use
so what can you learn from usability
testing you can see what it is about
your product or someone else's product
can be a competitor that makes people
struggle or get confused or make
mistakes so this is where this stumbling
thing comes in that's actually good like
you want to watch people struggle
because if someone does everything in
three minutes and has absolutely no
issues I guess it's good because you
found the product is easy to use but you
don't get any insights in terms of what
you can improve and your goal is to come
away from the test knowing okay this
screen is confusing here the button is
hard to find um the text makes people
think that the feature is not what it
actually is all of those things
so it kind of counter counterintuitively
you want people to struggle um but you
can also learn what people like about
the product they might just say oh wow
like this this really makes a lot of
sense I was waiting for this feature
I've I've heard that many times it
always is super nice to see people
excited about something that you're
building um and also you can get ideas
about what else to build so how to build
maybe the V2 of the of the feature that
you're thinking about um so all of these
you can uncover
so what do you need to have in order to
do usability testing you need
to get your participant to navigate the
UI and if you're doing it online which I
think is how we mostly would do
it hell hello yes all right um let's
maybe exchange this one thank
you
perfect
um where was it yes so if you're doing
the test remotely have the tester share
their screen so that you can see what
they're doing um because that's that's
where you get all those valuable
insights and ask the partic ipant to
accomplish some some task maybe task is
not even the right word it's more like a
scenario more in that very
soon again it's important for you not to
interfere as much as you possibly can do
not nudge the tester to a certain
correct path do not guide them as much
as you can if you see someone really
really struggling you can you can ask
but wait just a little bit longer even
though you you're like oh this is so
obvious you really you you if you just
like clicked on this button you would
get everything you need don't do it
don't do it observe what the user does
because that's how you uncover what your
users are likely to do in the real world
and see how they solve the problem and
that will help you understand how to
improve
so unlike user interviews where you can
just kind of go right ahead and start
interviewing the person before you do
usability testing you need to prepare
the person for how that's going to work
because it's slightly unusual for
someone to just sit in front of you or
even in front of their computer and do
this kind of fake is scenario and and
pretend that they're accomplishing
something so you need to get them in the
right mindset
um tell them to just think out loud and
be completely
unfiltered if they like something if
they don't like something they should
just tell you everything and tell them
to even pretend like you're not there
not in the room or not on the other end
of the zoom call just your goal is to
have them act as naturally as possible
it's hard and there's always going to be
an element of
of um awareness of being observed but as
much as you can encourage them not to do
that you should do it and remind them
that you're testing the UI so the
Prototype the product whatever it is and
not them this is very important because
people get self-conscious people start
worrying that they're making mistakes
people are starting to think oh no I
messed this up this person is going to
think that I'm stupid that I don't
understand things but I'm so smart
I've I've been working in this industry
forever how do I not get this people get
it in their head that's normal that's
why it's important to remind them this
is not about you this is about the the
UI uh if there if something about it
sucks we'll fix it don't worry and also
you you can even tell them I I didn't
even design this so you're not going to
hurt my feelings if you hate it even if
you did Design This say that you
didn't because that that just puts
people at ease about criticizing
something not everyone is comfortable
with
that and uh if it's a prototype make
sure to mention that it's a prototype
because some of them are pretty highdea
and people assume that they can just
click on everything most of the time
that's not the case make sure people
know
that okay so now we get to the tasks
things so as I alluded to don't think of
them as tasks because tasks are kind of
efficient and that's not your goal your
goal is to get someone to behave
naturally and people aren't always very
efficient the way they do things
naturally so how to write out a test
scenario choose a flow or a feature that
you want to test for example it's a
really really important flow for for
your product so if you're just starting
with with testing can be I don't know
for a wallet sending money checking
balances connecting to a dab stuff like
that um it can be a flow that you know
are is a particularly tricky one or
really really risky one it can be a flow
or feature that is new so once you kind
of get into the rhythm of doing ux
research um when there's a new feature
coming up that's a great a great moment
to to do um the testing because that way
you uncover problems before the feature
is implemented and you change the design
in advance so you save
time or you can test changes to up to
existing flows that you know users
already comfortable about but it might
be different so you want to make sure
that it stays comfortable for
them so as I mentioned scenarios are not
tasks so don't say Okay so now click on
the sign up button and fill out the
fields with your information that's not
a scenario that's an instruction and the
goal of a scenario is to give the Tester
the minimum absolute minimum of the
required information and learn how they
approach the the the scenario how they
would do it given their own
understanding their own assumption their
own habits
so for example if you're testing
exchange you can say Okay imagine it's
often good to start the test scenario
with imagine imagine your favorite token
just dropped 20% you want to take
advantage of this opportunity to buy
more how would you do that so you see
it's it's kind of phrased more like a
question like a hypothetical scenario
and that invites your tester to do
whatever it is most natural for them to
do and then you learn about how they
would do it in your actual product or if
it's a wallet you can say hey imagine
you made a new friend at Devcon stayed
out all night talking about ZK proofs
now you need to pay him back for for
dinner how would you do that and then
you sit back and
observe there will be struggles in
usability testing that's kind of the
name of the game as I've been telling
you
and there are different ways to handle
those struggles so for example the
participant can ask you a question but
not just like hey what's your favorite
color um it's like how do I do this or
what do you want me to to click on or
how where do you want me to navigate
to or if I do XYZ what will happen this
is the moment for you to tap into that
inner Serenity and be like that's a
great great question I'll answer it at
the end but for now just do whatever
feels right I want to learn about your
assumptions your habits what you would
do if you have any questions at the very
end of the test I'll answer all of them
if the participant seems
confused which most likely they will be
um you can kind of nudge them to explain
a little bit more about what is causing
the confusion so you can ask what do you
think is happening like I I see I see
that
you're wondering about something I see
that something is giving you
pause what do you think is the issue how
would you solve this problem because
sometimes especially if it's a prototype
you you can't really do everything and
people normally would I don't know close
the app open stack exchange ask a
question there or like Google something
so it's good to also give them space to
to tell you about
that and so if the participant is really
really really struggling so they're
about to lose all of their
money um rage quit the the test and you
can see that they're just not getting
anywhere you can say all right so I
think I I got the information that I
need would you like some help don't say
the thing that needs to happen right
away unless again like they're about to
click on the button that is going to
destroy their life forever
um unless that's happening just ask
would you like some help and
then let let the person tell you or you
can just say okay let's let's pause with
this one and go to a different flow do
something else
so this was the O overview of usability
testing um but these principles apply
to just doing ux generally so studies
show this not us saying this people have
looked into this and the study shows
that for usability testing just five
participants is enough to uncover about
85% of the
issues as long as those participants go
through the same flow so if you're
giving people the app and saying oh can
you use it for a bit and and do
something um then no five people aren't
aren't enough but as we said before you
need to be specific with your scenarios
with your questions so as long as you're
specific and and you give the same
scenario to everyone five participants
is enough to uncover a lot of the issues
that being said you need to make sure
that you're testing with the right
people if you go out into the world and
your product is geared towards protocol
Developers for example and you get five
casual coinbase users that like have
heard about metamask your insights will
not be relevant to what you're building
you need to make sure that you test with
the right users
and finally we love ux research like
that's why we're here but it can't
answer every single question that you
will ever have it will tell you about
user needs habits motivations pain
points that's a lot but it cannot tell
you for sure whether your product will
be successful or whether a particular
feature will be actively used by
everyone that's just there are some
limitations to what you can accomplish
with ux
research as you're uh as you're going
into uh starting your your your first
research um studies or continuing the
research studies maybe that you're
already doing um it's important to keep
in mind especially in web 3 that web 3
users are very privacy conscious um as
they should be um they're often very
suspicious especially of things that
sound too good to be true of offers for
money and exchange for do something of
random people sending them messages on
random platforms again as we all should
be um so it's very very important it's
important in any area of uh of research
even if you were doing e-commerce or
something like that but it's especially
important in web 3 that you give users
as much information as you can upfront
that you're very upfront about what it
is you plan to do what it is you plan to
ask of them what it is you plan to do
with their data um and that you keep the
requirements to join your your study at
an absolute minimum um so some examples
uh the first thing we want to do is you
want to inform somebody when you're when
you are approaching them or when you're
putting out a call for for um to recruit
participants um you want to inform
people what's going to be involved are
you going to require them to show their
their faces on video are you going to
require them to speak um what language
are you going to require them to speak
and do they have to speak perfect
English um do they have to share their
real name do they have to share their
real wallet address do they have to
share their screen do they have to
connect their wallet to adap uh do they
have to do a transaction with their
wallet do they have to uh will you take
a recording how will you where you will
store that recording um all of these
things uh are things that people need to
be informed about upfront so they can
make that informed decision about
whether it's worth it to join your uh
your study and so then it's best for you
if you have kept those requirements at a
minimum so that then people feel like
okay I've been told that if join this
study I don't have to connect my wallet
to any dap and so if I believe that then
there's very low risk for me right to
join this study okay and then you get
more likely to get participants if you
expect people to you know just hop on a
Discord call with you and share their
real wallet where they have all their
money and uh you know connect to your
your dap that's probably a hard sale um
also make it available that people can
ask uh to request deletion uh of their
data that you've taken from them of the
notes that you've taken from their study
after a certain point um let users give
consent granularly so ask them not just
yeah these are my requirements do you
consent to these uh what I typically do
is say hey I would like to take uh I
would like you to share your screen I
would like to take a recording of that
screen and of your audio um but you can
consent to these separately so you can
consent and say yeah I'll join your
study and you can watch my screen but
you can't record it let people consent
granularly to each different thing that
they're willing to share um and that
also makes them feel a lot more
comfortable um joining your your your
session um and again keep it Loose if
possible if somebody says no I really
don't want you to take notes or I mean I
really don't want you to record um then
just kind of be willing to say if if if
possible we be willing to say like yep
okay you know what that's fine I'll take
notes by hand if you're willing to kind
of slow down and speak slowly so I can
take those notes and people will be um
understanding of that um another is that
uh if people are going to be doing a
transaction for for this test um you
need to provide them with gas if they're
going to be swapping funds for this test
you need to provide them with the funds
for swapping never expect people to use
their own funds to join this uh this
this test of your product um that's not
ethical and um you know it's just also
kind of a bad sale It's A Hard Sell so
yeah always make sure that if you're
providing funds also provide gas funds
as well if they're necessary um if
they're sharing their screen uh let them
know that they only have to share um the
tab that your your uh that your dap is
in so a lot of people will just
automatically share their entire screen
which means if they switch over to
another tab if they open another app if
they open their metamask you can see all
that you can see what's in their
metamask they probably don't want to
share that with you so guide them to
only share the tab that is relevant for
you um and then uh yeah keep info
sharing requirements uh to a minimum
tell them they don't have to share their
name tell them that they can refuse to
answer a question uh if they don't want
to answer that question uh phrase
questions in ways like would you be
comfortable telling me or would you mind
sharing you know how many the size of of
a transaction how many do dollars you
trade in a typical transaction some
people don't want to share that some
people are fine with it it's best if you
if you phrase it in a way that lets them
know that they can say no I don't feel
comfortable sharing that and that's fine
um and then uh again in any area of user
research the number one Golden Rule is
always always always compensate your
user research participants they are
sharing their time with you they are
sharing their knowledge they are sharing
a piece of sort of their daily uh
behaviors their their thoughts with you
this is super valuable information uh
especially in web 3 where again there's
a lot of emphasis on the importance of
data and how we're all uh we all have
the right to our own private data right
so this is extremely valuable
information they're sharing with you um
they're doing it so that you can build a
better product um and the absolute
number one thing that you have to do is
make sure that they are compensated uh
for their time whether that's crypto
whether it's you know some um other perk
that you can offer them related to your
product or whatever make sure that it's
something that's worth it for
them I think this is your area of
expertise I mean it it can
be I think I know what I'm talking about
I don't know whether you can tell um so
let's talk about tools so all these
things you need to accomplish them
somehow um and we've got some
recommendations you don't have to follow
them exactly you can also do do your own
research see what works for you but just
so that you can have a certain idea of
what we personally prefer here here are
some suggestions so in terms of
recruiting users that is quite tricky in
crypto again because of privacy
considerations because a lot of people
are kind of anon um but there are plenty
of options so if your project has a
Discord you can use it to recruit your
user so the way I sometimes do it is
that if I'm researching a particular
feature for safe I search the feature
name in Discord and see what people have
asked questions about it and that way I
know okay this person cares enough about
this feature to ask a question about it
they probably using it at least a little
bit they what would be a good fit for
for the test you can do a popup in your
dab and just encourage people to sign up
to do to do research you can try a
dedicated recruitment platform there is
even a crypto specific recruitment
platform called despark you can try that
out you can also try out General user
research um platforms but they are very
unlikely to have advanced crypto users
so most most of the time you would get
people who you know have some crypto on
coinbase have maybe a tiny bit of
experience with metamask but nothing
nothing more advanced than that um you
can recruit here like there are plenty
of people and you can get to know
someone ask them what their struggles
are ask them what they're using in terms
of wallets or exchanges or whatever the
product is that that you're working on
and um if they seem like a fit you can
ask them whether they'd be willing to to
talk to you
um about your product for getting
consent uh a survey tool usually works
quite well so you can do Google forms or
type form or Survey Monkey whatever it
is that is easiest for you to get a hold
of totally fine for conducting user
interviews or tests Zoom is is a good
option because most of the people know
about it they're familiar with it they
have it set up often and you can easily
record the call
for scheduling you can use calendly
that's that's a nice option but whatever
zoom's internal schedule or Google
Calendar that also works for keeping
track of your tests and that seems like
an unusual thing to mention but trust us
you want to keep track of what you're
doing because at first you'll be able to
remember and then fast forward half a
year and you're like did we test this
feature did how many people how many
people saw this did we did we talk to
this guy he I remember his name but did
I pay him how much did I pay him I don't
remember keep track um so note who you
talk to when about what what their
contact info is whether you've paid them
and a spreadsheet tool like I don't know
Google Sheets notion air table any of
those are more than suitable and then
for analyzing your notes and recordings
and kind of storing them somewhere uh is
I would say the first area where you
might want to get a specialist tool so
all the other ones I've mentioned so far
you're probably already familiar with
you've used them for other non ux
researchy purposes for storing and
analyzing notes and recordings
it's it's probably worth it to at least
look into a specialist tool um both
Mindy and I use duvail and it's not the
only one at all out there but it's quite
easy to learn and it has a free version
that has plenty of features that um
should cover you if you're just
starting all right we've been talking
for a very long time and you're probably
sick of our voices um we're gonna talk
some more but now it's going to be
[Laughter]
[Applause]
different it's not over it's not over
can't I'm glad that someone was like oh
my God yeah they're gonna stop
talking we're gonna be talking but we're
gonna be we're gonna be talking directly
to
you okay that was yeah oh no never mind
I I didn't like it so I so I gave up
immediately
um so no I do want to ask a question so
how many of you have a project that
you're working on right now that you
would like to do use your research
with okay excellent perfect so what
we're going to do now we're going to do
a group exercise um I'm going to let you
group up with people at your table you
can group up with like the whole table
or just half the table or you know talk
to people it's a conference it has the
word confer in it you know like talk to
other people
um so you know and this is a workshop so
you can Workshop things with people
Workshop things withing they're like no
I can't talk to people all the
antisocial people are leaving it's fine
I would be leaving too if I weren't up
[Laughter]
here oh okay we have we have a few
antisocial people who are staying y'all
are the real MVPs Give It Up
[Laughter]
uh yeah so I will ask you again to find
a few people at your table that you can
do a little bit of work with um together
with your group uh you will pick a
project it can be one of your projects
that you're working on uh one of you at
the table is working on uh or we will
give you an example project uh that you
can just sort of imagine that you you're
working on uh and we will ask you to
create a research plan uh for that
project so that by the time you leave
here today you will have a ready too
research plan and you could even start
doing uh research on this project here
at Devcon um with uh with potentially
real users um yeah so where's the
clicker here's how it's going to work uh
first I'll ask you to again to pick a
project that you want to work on our
project that we're going to give you or
a project of someone at your table then
we'll ask you to choose uh one of the
two methods that we explained today
using usability tests or user interviews
which one whichever one seems more
relevant for the project um and then we
will ask you to uh make a research plan
and Christina will be handing out um the
guidelines here for uh how to do this as
uh as they hand those out I'm going to
be uh explaining a little bit more about
what is put is is is in this research
plan and I got to do the clicker as well
so um first you'll need to think about
well first you'll need to think about
what is my project which method are we
doing then you need to think about what
are the goals of this study what do we
aim to learn from this research is it
you know people's General thoughts about
um this area maybe if you're working on
on a daai project and you want to learn
people's General thoughts and like
experiences with AI uh maybe it's more
specifically like I have a project I
have a prototype I have a UI and I want
to know where people are struggling to
use it
um yeah so like what are your typical
goals um what are the
criteria uh what were how will you
recruit users what how uh what will you
have users consent to how will you get
their consent how will you compensate
the participants again very important uh
and then as well to plan out the
research uh the research
interviews um and Christina and I will
be walking around as you go ahead and
get to work and answering your questions
during this
process can I just STI it like that okay
cool huh
um if you need to refer back to any of
the the examples that we gave any of the
information that we shared during this
talk uh you can scan this QR code and uh
find all that information uh in a medium
article as well to help you out
CL
think
okay is anyone missing these or wants an
extra
copy okay one here one here cool coming
up
ch
if anyone wants more at any point just
let me
know
e e
[Music]
I e
that's for
[Music]
TR
e e
[Music]
B
f
[Music]
s
spe
t
about
you
e
e e
you
to e
[Music]
spe
ask
[Music]
you
problem
[Music]
the
want
[Music]
so
sh
[Music]
it's
the
hey so in about 10 minutes we'd love for
some of you to share what you have been
thinking about like things you have come
up with things you maybe still have
questions about things you're you found
trickiest what you've discussed um so
let's take another 10 minutes and then
we'd love to hear from some of you
you for
[Music]
you're
they
Happ
[Music]
ask
why
[Music]
ask
w
[Music]
s
don't
[Music]
the
o
[Music]
res
this
[Music]
pap
all right all right so we are really
really hello everyone Hi hi hi we're
really really curious to hear what some
of you came up with like what products
you decided to to research what research
plans you've you've come up with um
would anyone be willing to
share um what they what they've
discussed so far and and how that went
it it like this is not a quiz we're not
going to you know grade you on how well
you did but if you want some feedback
we'd be happy to to provide some um
we're just curious how this how this has
been going for you anyone willing to to
share just a little bit yay thank you so
much
much um I did both I did like brief in
interviews and then let the users test
out the
product did I that was not the
[Laughter]
activity well I executed the
plan so it was really insightful for me
because first of all what I really liked
is that I had like two different culture
users so because that was really
interesting to me what differences they
could see on my product no and I asked
about uh first of all just so you know
my product is an nft platform that
donates funds to Environmental
Conservation projects so I got a a
really good Insight of like what what
are the incentives that people have
behind purchasing nfts we also did um a
lot of technical issues that I hadn't
seen before I could see and also
like I I I had a good Insight that like
foreigners are interested in Latin
American Art because it's different it's
not like something that they us you
usually see on on other nfts so I
thought that was really cool and yeah
thank you so much both of you for
helping me and that's it yeah thank you
I I like that you mentioned that you
uncovered some technical issues that's
kind of the unintended bonus often of
usability testing you just you just find
a lot of bugs and often after usability
test I I have to write to some of our
devs being like oh also this happened do
you know why and they be like oh I've
never seen this interesting um yeah devs
devs like when user research happens as
well because then you find a bunch of
bugs for them to squash yeah for a
certain defition of
like cool thank you so much for sharing
thank
[Applause]
you um does anyone else want to share
yay
awesome test test hello everyone hi my
name is tiha I'm a ux designer so uh the
project that we're going for is the beta
basket example project so we're going
with uh user interview as a research
method and our research goal is to
understand what problem users have when
creating a wallet and for recruitment
our target audience is basically novice
users basic crypto knowledge but uh
crypto
Enthusiast and
recruitment what does it say here uh
okay how will we recruit them we have a
few options here um conference web three
events uh Reddit for forums and
Twitter and as for consent how will we
consent participants since we're using
um inperson user interviews uh we'll ask
them to consent for voice recording note
taking uh their time and also if they're
pref they prefer a one-on-one session or
um interview with a lot more people
so can you uh tell me about that with
one one person or or many people yeah
oneon-one if they prefer um a one-on-one
session like a private session or if
they're open to um talking to sharing
their um details with like other people
oh I see so yeah for example if we're
doing it at a conference or events there
might be people around so yeah yeah yeah
that makes sense and then for
compensation uh we're going with a few
options uh either our own token nft
access to side
events yeah swags or airdrop yeah yeah
all of these are are great yeah so for
um the interview itself uh the duration
will be between 15 to 20
minutes yeah and so these are the
questions that we would ask the first
one is um what are your goals getting
into crypto second which digital assets
are you interested in and then
um tell me about a recent we product
that you use and why did you choose to
use that specific product and yeah that
that last one is is a really really good
one because you kind of asking people to
just tell you about their recent
experience recency is good because they
still have a lot of memories about what
just happened and then it's it's
specific so that they don't have to
imagine things or lie to you just
because they want to fill the space you
know so and then this is kind of like a
a follow-up question question to that
question briefly explain a recent
problem that you have with that weet PR
product and what do you wish they would
have done better yeah that's all from us
thank you thank
[Applause]
you anyone else
oh over
here hello I'm Hussein uh founder or
developer and developer of Campus Arc
which is a decentralized learning
management system SS for companies and
communities uh we are the first uh LMS
on U
chain uh
and uh we chose usability test and uh
there will be five scenarios and for
each scenarios we will provide them five
or 10 minutes and actually uh I will use
this um plan for for my friends I will
start my friends in school so I I will
um ask them like uh follow the most
Basics basic flows uh for example
registrating verifying your
identity and our course modules
registrating AR modules because it's a
bit comp maybe a bit complicated for
non- crypto users because to register an
arc module you need to stake uh a sort
of token that's determined by the
publisher of the AR
module so
um CR criteria is uh being students
Community or company member of company
or
Community
um so yeah I I've written two uh uh
scenarios for now but we'll complete
them first um onboarding process explore
the onboarding process try to First
verify your identity with open campus ID
on chain verification using your wallet
or email it's important it's makes so
easier uh to onboard uh for non-crypto
users and then uh here are the required
Gus funds let's try to uh register for
Arc module and then third one maybe uh
go through the arc module experience and
tell me uh the difficulties or the good
parts you have
experienced uh fourth maybe
uh in each Arc modules there are some
parts that you collaborate some people
you give some feedback their Cotes they
give feedbacks to your Cotes and uh
what's the general it's yeah it's it's a
a bad question what's the general
experience you have uh I will make them
specific it's maybe fourth one and um
fifth one maybe um in campus Arc you can
register some Talent programs called Arc
Talent programs that's uh um uh
organized by web tree companies to
explore the best talents these programs
uh include some Arc modules to complete
each Arc modules have three or four Pro
projects to complete so uh the whole
idea of the arct
program uh to make them make it easier
to explore
talents uh like um
there there's a proof right uh
completing uh many project that's
determined by the company itself right
so I will uh ask them to join uh AR uh
arct programs and ask some specific
experience details so uh it's all thank
you thank
you one thing I will say is that um it
can be really hard doing usability
testing with your friends because it's
even harder to pretend like you can't
help them or even harder for them to
pretend like you're not there so uh you
really have to tell them in advance like
listen during this test I'm not your
friend yeah I will definitely say that
actually uh I'm planning to um like open
the uh screen record and leave them by
theirself so uh yeah uh I will get some
some consent about it sure okay it's an
important Point by the way thank
you I also wanted to ask that uh add
that maybe during all five scenarios is
a bit ambitious you you'll be surprised
how long it sometimes takes people to do
what you think of as basic tasks so
definitely like try going through
everything that you want your testers to
do MH um and and time
yourself and if it takes you someone who
knows the flows a
while budget for maybe three to five
times
longer uh for for your testers so it
might be necessary for you to prioritize
a little bit and be like okay all five
will take a while and and usability in
is quite tiring both for you as as the
moderator and for someone who's like oh
my God oh my God what do I do I don't
understand anything um so try
to yeah I want pick pick the ones that
are most important just focus on those
yeah I want the all of them in one
session yeah you're absolutely right
perfect thank you thank you who else
wants to we already have someone with a
with a mic oh excent he
uh hi guys I'm pran uh I had a big team
here uh um so I have uh a few designers
here uh and deil and there was this D
guy so uh mix bag of Team uh mix bag um
uh so um so we have an alpha product uh
we we're from 42 money and uh we
basically uh trying to build
decentralized front ends for smart
contracts and uh um we really haven't uh
figured out um who the users are
currently like we have like we're an
impass where we can you know uh go into
different directions so we're still
trying to figure that out so we started
with usability uh testing but then we
pred to uh user interviews and uh what
we found was that uh initially um the
users were hackers def analysts right uh
they could
um you know like just prompt the llm to
be able to generate front ends for smart
contracts like directly interact with
smart contracts right so found a lot of
useful things uh from this uh from this
exercise uh for example def finalists
need a little more um interactivity for
with drag and
drop uh they need a little bit a little
more interactivity with uh drag and drop
options like components uh uh they need
a way to be able to
research um where the yields are coming
from you know like defi Lama maybe or
something like that and uh the ux guys
uh the they had suggestions about um you
know having the Twitter feed of um the
of the smart contract that you want to
interact with as social proof as what is
exactly going on right so and uh data
about the smart contract is also useful
uh you know like security and uh you
know risk about the interacting with the
smart contract and then uh generating
the funding for it so yeah so basically
found out a bunch of things uh useful
and uh yeah cool thank
you anyone else wants to share yay
uh uh hello everyone uh we did a tiny
little bit of usability testing here so
oh yeah you also just went ahead and and
did the thing we we just did the thing
we just did the thing so um so uh for
you to understand the context um I work
at
UH graphin which is what we do we do an
alternative Android if you ever used
Android there are multiple different
types of Android and we have our own
type of Android and so very recently
very recently I helped our project uh to
work on the setup wizard thing if you
ever heard about it Setup Wizard is a
very first thing a user interacts with
when they uh open up the phone so and uh
we've decided to do a tiny little bit of
user experience testing and thank you
very much for doing that uh because we
uh my friendly colleague uh has never
ever used an Android phone as far as I
right okay long long time ago yeah yeah
very long time ago so
yeah no it's really good because uh it's
amazing to
see uh people with different uh
perspectives on six and so uh here are a
few things that um I can say about our
setup wiard for example um when the user
first like sets up the fingerprint uh
for their phone um it's usually a good
idea to show them like a like an
animation right to show where the sensor
is but it's still not clear and the
animation might not be clear and uh or
or other stuff so like not not not
everybody knows every single phone not
everybody knows where all the sensors
are or what kind of sensors are so it's
very complicated and so if you never
ever like so
oh I'm so sorry I'm jumping from place
to place yeah yeah but like uh it's one
of the one of the things that we'll work
on more is to show a better fingerprint
animation so that the user would know
whether the uh fingerprint sensor is
located yeah this is one of the things
and I think I should probably stop now
because otherwise I will talk a lot more
and this is like the first part of like
my two pages so yeah thank you thank you
that was really fun
[Applause]
anyone else
yes hey hi um so we had a lot of help
from the guys here uh actually we uh we
have a game we would like to create and
uh where they pinpointed the first uh
thing that that maybe if we think
something is an issue or a need for
users we we should we should ask them so
for example we thought that that
that uh um um ownership of assets
digital assets is a is a key question
and it turned out even in this table
it's not a key question for everyone
even though they play so uh yeah that's
maybe the colleague here phrased very
correctly that we started too technical
so we started that we must implement
nfts we must implement blockchain we
must implement or own coin or whatever
or own economy and it's not sure we have
to so yeah I think I uh I learned this
and it's uh back to the basics so thanks
guys thank you I just want to add it was
useful on the motivation of the game H
they they are building a web three game
so they could own the the Collectibles
so we wanted to get users who experience
spending a lot of time getting
Collectibles and uh losing them because
the company goes out of business
uh I don't know if you want to add
something no di di and
money
yes okay thanks that's I guess that's
all thank you
thanks um anyone else wants to share
[Music]
anything I think do we have any
questions on on M yeah so apparently you
know how at the beginning those those of
you who are here from the very beginning
uh you know how we told you that there
would be a QR code for you to ask
questions well that was a little bit of
a lie there was a QR code and you could
submit questions but apparently they
didn't go to the place that we could
actually see so if anyone submitted
questions it's uh too bad because we
didn't see them yes you have a question
yes please go for it okay I have a
question so uh you guys said that it is
important to um
find the right customer to interview
with so how to find the right Customer
because uh maybe we uh choose randomly
five customer maybe they just a small
group of our total customer so uh uh do
do we have any rule or do we have any
uh anything to Define out the right
customer I can start so um the five
person rule is for usability testing the
reason why it typically works for
usability testing is because um
usability testing is very much based on
like psychologically how a person
understands a UI how they react to
certain things um and so people who are
in Fairly similar buckets will T
typically have the same reactions and
the same understanding of those things
so if these people are already your
users and you do a use ibility test with
them it's typically five people is is
okay um so that's the first thing now if
you are looking at um a larger group
like a very large user base and you want
to do like user
interviews uh or if you're just choosing
people off the street or choosing people
at Devcon you probably want to write
some criteria and that depends on really
on your business um like what what what
you're trying to do for your business so
if you're building a game game and
you're trying to learn um you know why
some people don't play web 3 games then
you want to look for people who don't
play web 3 games but who do use web 3
but do use web 3 like why are these
people doing web 3 but they're not doing
um you know web 3 games or if you are if
you have a large you know like I I can
talk about you know my my um the Dow
that I contribute to um we have uh we
have um an exchange platform for example
and many different people go and swaps
on the exchange so when we're doing user
research we have to think about okay um
if it's for a specific feature then we
want to talk to maybe people who use
that feature if it's for you know if
we're interested in how to improve the
product for people who do very small
trades or for people who do very large
trades we need to look at the data and
try to find the users that do those
kinds of Trades um if we're interested
in going on a different chain if we're
adding a new chain maybe we're going to
add base we want to like understand base
users then we need to find people who do
like web 3 users who do swaps on an
exchange uh and use base so like the
criteria can add you know depending on
how specific you need to be for the
particular project something to add I I
think you you covered most of it the
only thing I would add is that there is
essentially no way to avoid some element
of Randomness like you said if if you
just pick pick five of your users isn't
that kind of random and you should have
criteria you should be aware of okay
what exactly you want to test or
interview about and what kind of users
care about this the most or could care
about this the most but if you already
done that you've defined your criteria
you've searched for those particular
users there will be more than five most
likely that fit those and there there is
an element of Randomness and that's
okay yeah user research is not an exact
science what do you
mean I mean it's even in you know
especially when we're talking about
qualitative research when if you're
talking about quantitative research and
you're trying to get a really
statistically significant sample and
like you know look at large amounts of
data then things are different but with
qualitative research it's it's
qualitative it's subjective it's not an
exact science and some things will be
random and some things won't exactly fit
and that's just kind of part of the joy
of uh of doing this work actually you
have to be comfortable with um with
things not always fitting together
perfectly yeah does that answer your
question yeah perfect thank you anyone
else
yes um hi um how to create user research
on a products which primary focus is not
the UI but rather providing some
functionalities like imagine AWS without
DUI everything that it provides but
without
DUI well so what can you give um I mean
when I said UI without shiny buttons
like you can still use the terminal you
can still call some apis basically you
can still use the product but there are
nothing like the login with I don't know
buttons for input Fields it's basically
pure the functionality
like how to cond
resarch yeah yeah yeah yeah so so how to
conduct a research for for a toolkit for
example well again it depends on what
kind of research we're talking if it's a
if it's an interview then you don't need
the UI at all anyway um and if you want
to do some kind of usability testing you
actually don't necessarily need um you
know your typical like log page for it
to be usability testing some people do
usability testing with you know vacuum
cleaners uh we're just we happen to to
work in in an environment where
everything kind of has a certain number
of familiar elements but that's just
because uh we're all kind of in this
same context but you can do usability
research on like on on this chair if you
wanted to as long as you ask someone to
use the product in whatever way that
makes sense like using the terminal or
coding or using the developer
documentation anything that that might
be involved in that um you will still
get information on okay this is um a
struggle this is where someone gets
confused they have a certain expectation
and they think that something will
happen and it doesn't or they're like oh
I wish
I could also do this so you'd still get
all of that valuable information even if
there's no like sign up but is it
realistic and you sit with the people
yeah that's what I wanted to ask next
like is it realistic to do it live or
just tell them okay when you are done
with using it checking the documentation
and everything else just please then
provide the answer on so so maybe you
can think about what what do you care
like it's like that they can integrate
easily your product that they think it's
a great product like uh which problem do
you want to solve for them H maybe if
it's a market for that uh once you have
that clear maybe you you can design an
exercise with these people or like or
like a survey with this target group
group where you would gather this
information does it make no I mean the
first part is perfectly clear like okay
you know what you need to do but then
when you when you create the product
like that part of testing because I mean
you mentioned videos audio that I mean
that last for an hour or two but
basically to read through the docks to
try it out it takes much more time so
I'm not sure if can like can we do it
just sit here this is the laptop please
do it I don't know two three 4 hours I
mean do the people test the product live
for four hours or not I don't know or
basically tell them okay please do this
whenever it's comfortable comfortable
for you and provide us the feedback
sometime in the future so I would say
that um if you're doing feedback
afterwards then an interview is actually
a good way to do it because often you
know you send out a survey like a
feedback form people don't like forms
people really really don't like filling
out forms and if they can avoid doing
that they probably will especially if
they need to like write texts oh forget
it um so here you really might want to
get those people um as close to the
moment that they did use the product as
possible and then ask them okay think
about the the moment that that you used
our our product let's say yesterday um
was there anything in particular that
you struggled with did you notice
anything missing um what was the point
where you're like oh they have this
thing isn't that nice was there anything
that surprised you uh in a positive way
so kind of just try to get people to
reflect on that experience and and that
might be a better option because sitting
somewhere with a person for 4 hours it
it can be done but it's kind of an
intense thing to do um so maybe not
necessarily the the right way to to
start you know yeah okay thank you thank
you um and I think we are incredibly out
of time we have one minute left so
anybody has a quick question yes oh no
two people have what I mean we we'll be
still we'll be still here like outside
of of the of the classroom if you want
to talk to us afterwards but uh yeah if
if someone wants to do a super quick
question then yes yeah uh this will be
super quick yeah so basically we at an
impass where we're trying to figure out
uh with the product uh where we like we
have like sectors of users which we want
to Target and uh um if you want to
Target a specific sector then uh we need
to build the product a little
differently right and uh um we're trying
to decide which uh path to take from uh
user experience and user design you like
how do we how do we do that you're so
sneaky this is not a quick question this
is not a quick question we we will we
will answer it outside of the classroom
thank you so much to everyone who who
came and stayed uh I really appreciate
it and yeah thank you so
much sure
[Music]
back back back
o
[Music]
back
see
[Music]
h
back back
back back back
[Music]
back back back back
back back
[Music]
e
back back back
back back
[Music]
back back back
back
[Music]
back back back
he
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
back back
back back back
[Music]
back back
what
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back back
[Music]
e
n
[Music]
let
back
[Music]
back back
he
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
back back back back
so
[Music]
w
back
back back back
[Music]
he
back back
[Music]
back back back
back
[Music]
back back back
he
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
back back back
back back back back
[Music]
that's
back back back
[Music]
back
back back back
[Music]
he
back
[Music]
back back back
oh
[Music]
he
back
[Music]
back back back
back
[Music]
back back
back
[Music]
see
back back
[Music]
back back back
back
[Music]
this
back back back
back
[Music]
back back
back back back
back
[Music]
back back back
he
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
back back
[Music]
back
what